michael smith back here in the rich
eisen show how are you michael
yo you got larry david in the studio
yeah he's coming he's coming yo that's
dope you want to come over mike
tell him i said what's up
i will do that i mean he don't know who
the hell i am but tell him i said what's
up hey man look larry is a die hard
sports fan and a sports viewer and he's
out there he's got some ideas on what he
wants to do for the nfl and he thinks he
can be an offensive and defensive
coordinator in the nfl and i believe him
he's got a shot i don't know if he'd be
effective i'd just like to hear him call
plays i would love it too i would
absolutely love it too well he's got to
come to the sideline hey coach what do
you think yeah he did come up with years
ago when
prior to this show's birth um we you
know i had my podcast on nfl network um
on the tv side brockman was the editor
of that show
and um producing in the studio um at any
rate uh larry came on and he came up
with the idea of a double flick so a
flea flicker but instead of the running
back flicking it back to the quarterback
the quarterback then flicks it to
another person a second a double flick
and then that person throws it down the
field
so that's the idea of the type of play
calling that he would do dude's a genius
i'd rather i don't want him to just be a
play call i want to be the commissioner
i want to hear him well he's got some
ideas of well this would be great again
that's hour three and then once that's
over i'll be calling into you or zooming
into your show uh with uh michael holly
um
are you um
how how many alarms is the fire for the
lakers after that first loss
for you
what do you got for me uh
i mean
two okay maybe okay i mean they're
playing a long game they're long in the
tooth and they're playing a long game i
mean you know what do they have three
holdovers
from last year
i mean
you know i didn't expect them to come
out and the warriors are good they were
they were good last year they struggled
to score
uh when they needed to but they're deep
and they're good they're gonna get
better
um
so i wasn't shocked by last night i mean
westbrook
i mean you know
playing down to expectations i guess you
know that was very russell westbrook
like in term on his worst night and for
it to be opening night it certainly
lends to quite a bit of panicking you
know
or or confirmation bias if you already
was skeptical about how
this team would gel and how these pieces
would fit certainly last night you know
small sample size you're looking pretty
smart right now but in the long run i
think they figure it out and on the
bright side bottom line is anthony davis
looked great
lebron james looked like lebron james in
year 19 look like he's aging backwards
and so if those two guys are healthy at
the end
they're going to be playing deep into
the season and i think they'll figure
out rotations and chemistry and and fit
and all that kind of stuff as the season
goes on they may not be a dominant
regular season team but i think they'll
be really good come play off time so uh
you know as long as they avoid the uh
the playing game then um you know
although i'm sure the nba would once
again
sign for last night's matchup being the
play in game match up again just like
last year um but that was all
injury-related as well so how do you
guess the against the sons last year
well i mean we forget yeah no no no i
know that the lakers had to beat the
warriors first right they were the
warriors though oh absolutely right
right
like it's for all their flaws last year
yeah for all their difficulties last
year all their struggles last year they
were up against the suns before anthony
davis got hurt so i'm not saying it's
just it could be a two-man show and they
beat anybody with just those two healthy
but if those two are healthy
i mean you know it's going to take a lot
to beat them even if they are flawed
around them well then what how do you
see the chemistry working with um with
russ i mean how how do you see him
working in
to this two-man game what do you think
well i don't i mean i don't necessarily
know chemistry is a broad term i don't
necessarily know what the issue with
russ is chemistry i mean russell has led
the league in assist several times he's
a willing passer
russ is go rush's flaws are not going to
change he's not going to all of a sudden
become a good outside shooter i think he
was 107 outside the paint that's about
right like they didn't get him for a
shooting they got him to
handle the ball when lebron on the bench
or take some other playmaker
responsibility off of lebron
um
what if they're sharing the floor i
don't think they should share the floor
that much
um but russ has not all of a sudden
become a great shooter
um
the issue with this team more than
anything is probably gonna be defense
and we saw it last night but the
warriors they do that to people man i
mean i don't know if this is so much of
an indictment of the lakers in their
shortcomings last night as much as it
was a reminder of how well the warriors
played basketball i mean they move the
ball with the best of them i mean steph
curry called the triple double trash yes
they're a damn good team and and the
lakers are going to lose to a lot of
teams
this year but when they get into in the
playoff mode and if lebron and anthony
davis are healthy and russ
is more efficient than he was last night
and can minimize the turnovers and
carmelo anthony gives you a spark off
the bench and so on and so forth if they
can defend that's gonna be the big thing
is can they defend they can defend i
still like them come play all the time i
i have the nets
you know sorry i have the nets beating
the uh lakers in the finals and that
doesn't change for me after one night
even though both of those teams
uh emerged from last night with a lot of
questions michael smith the brother from
another right here on the rich eisen
show we're going to give our nba finals
predictions and mvps and so forth later
on on the show
uh i am now making you daryl mori
congratulations you're now down
yeah yeah just for the moment what have
i beaten up who have i beaten up
consistently
every time i've come on and talked with
you about this i know
once
so then it's a self-flagellating
conversation we're about to have here so
what do what do you do if you're daryl
now what how how do you handle this now
okay if i'm daryl mori right now how do
i handle this
okay i'm daryl murray i'm not michael
smith because michael smith told daryl
maury yeah you've been saying his long
time ago yes i know but if i'm daryl
murray yeah i'm not reversing course
because that's not what i do
if i'm darrell mori
ben simmons is nothing but an asset
these players are nothing but expendable
assets with the exception of joel embiid
i'm always looking to upgrade
and so since i am not looking at this
from a human perspective i'm simply
looking at this on a spreadsheet
um
i
am not reversing course i'm going to
continue to let ben simmons
dig his own proverbial grave
and i'll wait and see how the season
plays out
and if another team wants to come closer
to meeting my asking price then and only
then will i trade ben simmons in the
meantime i will continue to happily
collect fine money from ben simmons
until he figures out that i have all the
leverage here and that he's not going
anywhere until i say he's going
uh somewhere
and in the meantime doc rivers your job
is to coach the guys that are there
you're right joel embiid your job is not
to babysit ben simmons you guys do your
job i'll do my job and unless and until
ben simmons is ready and willing to do
his job we'll just keep finding him and
suspending him accordingly all right now
congratulations uh because you did so
well there uh even though you didn't
want to do that um you're now rich paul
congratulations
um i'm happy i'm with adele so
well outside of that i was today years
old when i found out that rich paul is
with adele yeah right oh yeah
yeah i mean i didn't know that yeah yeah
that breakup is gonna make a hell of an
album for her one day that dude is
winning at life i know so so let me ask
you this um outside of trying to get ben
simmons to the lakers uh what do you do
now uh what do you do if you're rich
paul
to handle this situation how do you
handle this i think you tell it's like
look ben
listen man
it's time for us to have a hard
conversation
and it's time for you to know thy self
believe that with socrates you have to
know thy self
and you are not this guy
this is not you man and by this is not
you i don't mean it's beneath you
to throw a temper tantrum i mean
you're not that good
i love you i know what you are and i
know what you aren't and you're not
james harden as in
you can go and and
you know
disrupt practice or throw basketballs at
people or standing up you can go do that
and there's still a team ready willing
and able
to give up the farm to get you the way
the nets were to rescue james harden
from houston last year
part of the reason is that the sixers
aren't looking for draft picks in return
a trade is too complicated at this point
you're not jimmy butler okay you're not
going to show up at practice and say
give me all the backups and beat the
starters and prove just how valuable you
are okay you are not helping yourself
right now the rest of the league knows
that you're flawed and now you're
showing yourself to be fragile so as
your agent i'm telling you what you need
to hear not what you want to hear and
what you need to do instead of showing
out is to ball out put it behind you
show up you only got to be friends you
ain't got to be partners you ain't got
to be brothers but what y'all got to do
is work together to rehabilitate your
image all those shots you were making
and pick up in the summer i need you to
make some of those in the game because
right now your trade value is not
increasing you're doing nothing to get
moved right now by getting thrown out of
practice
the only way yes we're talking about
practice the only way you're going to be
able to get traded is if you show up and
play and be a professional i know you
don't like them but that's the real and
you don't pay me to lie to you you pay
me to tell you the reel
well done round of applause right there
uh and last role play for you michael
smith congratulations you're now kendall
jenner uh no i'm just joking um
right there i'm sorry no no but uh
i i just don't know how i i think the
more is more real right
um
although you have to think rich paul has
to be saying that to him too
so
i don't know what the way out of this is
he's truly because
if he shows up and practices normally
right thursday they're going to dress
them right they're going to dress them
friday night in philadelphia
and because that's what they want they
want them to get a taste of the
competition and a taste of you know
whatever medicine might be had and for
him to then wake up the next day and
realize the world is still spinning and
he's still ben simmons with an
incredible upside with a monster
four-year contract that makes him
generationally wealthy
and then they just get to the next news
cycle without him getting kicked out of
practice and then suddenly they can
start telling other gm's yeah well
forget about all that nightmare that we
just went through he won't do that to
you how about a full dollar on the
dollar instead of cents like
right isn't that the best case scenario
for everybody involved right now no
actually okay well actually i think the
best case scenario
is
the description that doc rivers has
given the situation
at every turn this off-season on your
show and conferences all over the place
doc has talked about how this happens
all the time in sports you know there's
disagreements all the time move on and
get past it right
because
again
look michael we're you're breaking up i
don't know if you're on some sort of uh
i don't know
put them on hold for a second i've never
had what sounds like a landline
disintegrate quite like that mike you
want to you want to i mean i'm i'm
thinking it was he was moving around
okay you want to try it one more time
again you there michael
oh
you know his phone's kind of crapping
out right there oh no i can't as you
know
i can't have this and it's not that the
phone goes down it's just at the end of
the conversation and you know how i am
yeah i'm like the mariana rivera of
interviewing i need closure maybe this
is something we should ask larry
yes later on like whose responsibility
is it to call back it's a good one for
closure on the phone right let's try
them again mike you there yeah i'm here
okay very good
you started you said you were going
through like doc was saying and all of
that stuff that's them that was your
fault dawg my phone ain't bootleg like
that
[Laughter]
all right we'll take we'll take the head
so first of all you're saying doc wait
but sidebar no i'm just kidding the
sidebar yeah like i think i'm one of the
last people to actually have a landline
in my house like every time i say i have
a landline people like really by the way
you're not wrong and not only that your
voice is
excellent and it sounds great on the
landline and um and i appreciate
landlines and then all of a sudden when
they go out it just it's it's it's just
it's a gut punch to me personally
certainly at the end because because i i
need closure i would literally would
have called you back 15 times just to
say goodbye like that's the way i am i
appreciate that
i totally respect when i relate to that
because i can't tell you how many times
stuff happens on our show and it just
drops off and it pisses me off the rest
of the show but i'll make my answer
quick the best case scenario yes is for
i think the fixers are being sincere no
matter what they may have said after
game seven or didn't say the entire
offseason i think the sixers are being
sincere that they know that they are a
better team they were the number one
seed last year in a regular season they
are a better team
with ben simmons
especially absent a dream trade that
daryl mori thinks will make this team
better a la bradley beal or damian
lillard who's already on record is
saying i ain't leaving philly okay
so
the sixers are better if ben simmons
shows up and plays
ben simmons needs to be careful what he
wishes for because i don't know who's
telling him that the organization has
held him back to this point as reported
in athletic instead of vice versa he
needs to be careful what he wishes for
okay because if he ends up in nba
siberia
then all those all defensive team
selections and all-star selections go
out the window okay he benefits by being
with joellenbee contrary to what he may
believe or is being told lastly
and listen i'm not from philly i've been
to philly a few times i love philly love
their fan base love their passion love
their knowledge
and they're going to root for the
laundry
and ben simmons
as much as he may feel like he's been
ostracized and can never return to
philadelphia they may boo him the first
couple of times
but it'll get old after a while and
those fans are sophisticated enough to
realize that it doesn't help their team
to make life difficult for one of their
key players and those fans will also
follow doc rivers and joel embiid who
are all willing to move on so if they
move on the fans will move on and it
won't be that bad for that long for ben
simmons
until playoff time if he clams up again
but in the meantime
it can work it can be fine so the best
case scenario for me in my mind for all
parties involved is to turn the page on
last year and try to make this work as i
said ad nauseam if if daryl mori thinks
so highly of ben simmons has to attach
an astronomical price tag to him then
why are you trying to move him in the
first place
you know
and and for ben simmons i don't think
the grass is green on the other side
basically ask marvin bagley how he's
like in sacramento that's basically what
you're doing
right
like ask
get him on the phone with his agent and
see you you know like um
thanks for the call really appreciate it
great landline brother seriously uh i
gotta go see if i need a new cortland
song what am i talking to you about
later what do you want to what what
should i plan for later on
[Music]
well yeah
you haven't had your rundown meeting yet
is it what you're saying you haven't no
i mean the rundown meeting is is me uh
it's 2041. we got a couple more hours
um definitely won't talk to you about
this nfl season sure you being the
all things nfl guy that you are uh we
were talking about this yesterday sure
whether or not and give this some
thought or maybe you've already given a
thought knowing you uh whether or not
you believe that this season
is off to the best start in recent
memory given all the overtime games yes
all the games coming down to the final
minute especially prime time blah blah
blah sure
uh look ahead to tomorrow night's game
with you okay um sounds good
you know and maybe uh we'll keep talking
about the nba season i'm i i got a
little bone to pick as i'll let y'all go
though i'll let y'all let me go more
precisely
the rule is you're supposed to give
finals predictions and mvp predictions
like before the season starts it's kind
of cheating
not really i mean you know um
it's not like somebody got off the
lakers just because they lost last night
oh wait a minute let me check my email
yeah i did that yeah or or like how do
you not have giannis at the front of the
mvp conversation like remember giannis
fatigue like oh yeah he can't win
another mvp like
look it's just something like that no
there was so much going on yesterday
blame ben simmons and his sweatpants
that that that knocked our preview of
the nba out of our rundown yesterday
yeah did you see him in his sweatpants
he was that was well i mean sham sharani
is coming on later on we'll talk to him
about it we'll talk
so hey and then so bring that knowledge
i will show later because we don't know
about that we're going to talk about the
natural
man we just see where it goes and then
get some michigan trolling in
you know wonderful i look forward to it
i'll see you later uh with michael
michael smith thanks for the call you
take care appreciate y'all be good
michael smith michael holly brother for
another i'll be joining him later
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here